bon ça va mais c'est très bien ça fait
plaisir de vous revoir parce que je
retrouve là les meilleurs chroniqueurs
du paf le plus beau public du monde et
surtout surtout le plus grand animateur
du monde après texte benjamin castaldi
quoi leur dire bien sûr foule applaudit
bien fort et comme ça que vous c'est
comme ça que vous fêter mon retour quoi
oui bon scolaire sont des 22 janvier
qu'elle a été très sympa qui vous a
remplacé d'une personne moustachu chez
moi ça va la remplacer
non mais c'est vrai qu'on est très
content de vous revoir ça fait plaisir
parce que fait contre finir l'année 2018
comme ça parce que benjamin c'est une
année exceptionnelle pour vous c'est la
première année que vous ne divorce y est
pas et c'est vrai que c'est quand même
un accident de motocyclette en même
temps vous n'aviez pas la bonne tenue
pour conduire regardez-moi ça c'est pas
normal
vous avez partie des fringues de bono du
bois c'est pas normal
un conseil mettez des bonnes bonne
conduite de la moto après tout c est moi
j'adhère basket ça va ça va coûter
talons pas le bras dans le dos l'avion
mentir bon alors tout cas personne nous
oblige bon ben vous savez on regarde les
vidéos tous ont regardé toutes les
vidéos ou postiers pour donner une bonne
nouvelle comme comme celle ci qui était
pleine d'émotion depuis votre lit
d'hôpital regarder ce que craint le fait
très émouvant quand le pays a connu
entre la sécu et bien payée 600 euros
par mois
il était accroché j'ai quelque chose à
vous dire oui
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
aucun trucage en tout cas on est ravi de
votre tour et pour fêter cela je suis
ravi des vôtres je suis content on va
tomber c'est ben beau résumé de carrière